vous habitez en ville et vous avez
l'impression qu'il y a de moins en moins
d'étoiles dans le ciel même au beau
milieu de la nuit vous ne rêvez pas une
nouvelle étude démontre qu'en milieu
urbain les étoiles disparaissent
littéralement à vue d'oeil on est en
train de perdre le noir du ciel et on
est en train de perdre les étoiles c'est
vraiment catastrophique parce que on
abuse de l'éclairage
urbain les chercheurs ont utilisé les
données provenant d'un réseau
international de 50000 bénévoles qui ont
observé durant une décennie certains
groupes d'étoiles la vaste majorité des
participants l'expérience sont en fait
des astronomes amateurs ils ont un
intérêt particulier pour ça donc ce sont
de bons observateurs du ciel qui sont
capables de repérer les constellations
et de se souvenir oui c'est vrai je
voyais cette étoile et je ne la vois
plus maintenant l'étude ne laisse aucun
doute la pollution lumineuse est
beaucoup plein intense qu'on ne croyait
jusqu'ici en 2017 on estimait qu'elle
augmentait de 2% par année on parle
maintenant d'une augmentation annuelle
de 7 à 10%. les chercheurs évaluent que
là où dans un ciel urbain on peut voir
aujourd'hui 250 étoiles en 2040 on
enverrait plus qu'une centaine une des
sources du problème selon eux l'immense
popularité de l'éclairage extérieur avec
une lumière bleutée très polluante celle
des diodes électroluminants on a vendu
en fait les LED comme étant des des
outils pas chers à utiliser qui
permettait d'économiser de l'énergie et
donc des sous donc on a décidé d'en
mettre partout mais dans l'immédiat
c'est la perte progressive d'un
spectacle quotidien extraordinaire qui
est préoccupant aujourd'hui si on
regarde on consulte la vaste majorité
des gens pour leur demande saviez-vous
ce que c'est que la Voie Lactée
avez-vous déjà vu la Voie Lactée presque
personne ne sait où regarder pour voir
la Voie Lactée ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal